don't do it made up come to I'll do that
one what's that I don't know I just made
it up okay okay and we have I'll be
inviting myself
yeah I'll do myself hey hey we got a um
we got a real special guest tonight I
didn't think that we could get this big
but you know I would run into him at the
comedy store and he'd be like yo B
what's up I want to be on Taco Bell have
it was alright you know that kind of
thing and now he's here we have Russell
Peters giving run ok stay quiet the
whole time it was very good he wanted to
say something the whole country you I
mean dude it's like I want to say this
like to throw props out okay throw some
props out or throw them out if they're
getting stale throw them out I know they
don't like it right if I wanna say this
dude but it's like you're probably one
of the biggest comedians on planet earth
not in the country but just in globally
you're like one of the biggest I was in
Thailand mm-hmm
shooting a shitty movie years ago I
remember there were only two years ago
or whatever and I know and the whole
crew of this movie Russell Peters is
playing can you get he asked me to get
tickets right I got the text but it was
like years later I think I got it and
then I replied but you didn't get my
report maybe I didn't get your reply
yeah yeah yeah yeah I remember you
remember that I do
oh wow it's probably in my history yeah
so would you but would you of if if I if
we had talked you would have got me some
tickets I never sent oh man I [ __ ] up
a [ __ ] movie it was June of 2014
oh [ __ ] Wow really you still have it
you don't delete you don't eat things on
no actually was not June of 2014 that's
when you asked me to tweet about you
doing the Denver Comedy Works I was
desperate yeah dude and then 2013 2013
you guys made about your champion
[Laughter]
all right Bobby can you do my Tiger
belly on Monday oh yeah yeah listen can
I do it the following week and here we
are
Russell let me say something those okay
can I just say something I'm waiting for
a third I need a third tweak for ya I'm
desperate when I get desperate right I
reach out to people that I know that
have a large following to help me out
okay and the reason why I went to you
because you did it every time I would go
to other people to they wouldn't do it
and I really appreciate those little
helps that you gave me no thanks
[Music]